SPEAKER: We understand
that retail banks depend
on Temenos apps to
process essential banking
transactions, from deposits and
withdrawals to critical loans.
In this demo, our fictional
bank has deployed their Transact
core banking app running on
new OTP distributed database
on Anthos Google
Kubernetes Engine, or GKE,
giving them the flexibility
to run production workloads
on premises in their
own data center
while also having
a secondary site
on Google Cloud
set up for bursting
to handle unforeseen
surges in core banking
transactions, failover to the
cloud for disaster recovery,
and autoscaling back down to
maintain business as usual.
This full demo, if done
live, spans one hour,
so keep in mind that we
have edited for time.
Let's take a quick
tour of the dashboard.
Starting on the upper left, you
can see the ActiveMQ message
queue count.
Going down the left side, you
see the Transact and NuoDB CPU
and NuoDB commits
on-prem and in the cloud.
We're using JMeter to load the
transactions into ActiveMQ.
So on the upper right
chart, we present the number
of transactions per second.
In this demo, the
system on-prem is
built to handle a
maximum normal load
of 20 transactions per second.
Going down the right side, see
the two GKE nodes ready to go,
with the ability to
autoscale up to five nodes.
Transact on premise is set
scale up to three replicas.
After that, to support
additional load,
Transact is set to scale up
to 19 replicas in Google Cloud
GKE.
And on the bottom, we show
how NuoDB Transaction Engine
is also set to scale
up to three replicas.
As we've been going
through the tour,
you can see that, with the
exception of a brief spike,
the system has been
processing a fairly steady
and, quote unquote, "normal
load" of about 13 transactions
per second.
In the ActiveMQ
chart, you can also
see that, for the most
part, transactions
are being processed right away.
So messages are not queueing up.
All looks good so far.
We've started fast
forwarding, so you
can see how Google Cloud
can help with a sudden surge
up to 150 transactions
per second and beyond.
GKE Transact replica
scaled to 19,
and GKE nodes autoscale up to 5.
NuoDB transaction
engine will also
scale up to 2, with
the CPU utilization
rate exceeding the target.
Messages are building
in the queue.
We fast forward more to show
how the system is coping well
with the increasingly heavy
load, and that activity
in the NuoDB transaction
engine replicas is converging.
Finally, we reach peak activity
of about 250 transactions
per second.
Messages really start
accumulating as just too
much for the system to handle.
Now, we simulate a
worst case scenario
in this demo, failure on
premises at the maximum load.
In this DR scenario,
Cloud is just
about managing the messages,
while the on-prem site is down.
After about 470
seconds of downtime,
the on-prem data center
is operational again.
Next, we'll show how
transact on Google Cloud
is set to automatically scale
back down when transaction
loads return to normal.
Messages have gone down to zero,
transaction engine activity
converges, and Transact
replicas in Google Cloud scale
back to 1.
And NuoDB transaction
engine in the cloud
also scales down to 2.
The system in the cloud
continues to scale down.
NuoDB transaction
engine replicas
are now down to a minimum.
And the GKE nodes are starting
to scale back down from 5 to 2
as well.
In conclusion, this
demo showed how
Transact can be set up to burst
seamlessly from on premises
to Google Cloud to handle
unforeseen spikes in load,
how we can failover
to the cloud,
and also autoscale
back down again
to maintain business as usual.
Thank you for watching.